das hier ist Gülcan Gülcan ist 60 Jahre
alt kommt aus Ankara ist eine begnadete
Köchin aber allen voran ist sie eine Oma
ich glaube in dem Zeitpunkt wo eine Mama
zur Oma wird kann sie doppelt so gut
kochen automatisch das ist einfach so
ein Naturgesetz genau aus diesem Grund
weil Omas einfach am besten kochen
können existiert dieses neue Format ich
möchte zu verschiedenen Omas aus
verschiedenen Ländern gehen und
authentisch die Landesküche von ihnen
gekocht bekommen auf diesem Kanal haben
wir schon viele Sachen gegessen das
teuerste das bestbewertete
Sternerestaurants aber wenn wir ganz
ehrlich sind wo schmeckt am besten bei
Oma ich glaube das ist ein tolles Format
weil es einfach so Einblicke gibt und so
echte Geschichten echte Leidenschaft zum
Kochen zeigt ich würde sagen wir machen
uns auf den Weg zur gülcem setzen uns an
den gedeckten Tisch und erleben ist ein
Tag lang von einer türkischen Oma
bekocht zu werden
[Musik]
vielen Dank dass wir hier sein dürfen
ich weiß es sehr zu schätzen das sieht
alles toll aus möchtest du dich
vorstellen sagen wer du bist
du heute für uns gekocht hast ist
typische Küche die du gerne kochst was
du gerne isst alles selbst gemacht
das mag ich auch so gerne weil Omas die
die kennen keine Mühe sondern die machen
einfach das beste Essen überhaupt was
ist das was wir hier haben
das ist Linsensuppe oder oben drauf
gebräunte Butter also wirklich ich freue
mich sehr dass er hier sein dürfen
sollen wir probieren super das erste
Gericht im Kühlschrank hat für uns
gekocht sag mal so viel es gibt noch
einiges zu entdecken ich habe wirklich
das Gefühl so ich fühle mich als wäre
ich dein Enkel der zum Essen kommt ja
ich muss danke sagen okay probieren wir
mal
wow sehr lecker sehr gut nah mit Zitrone
ich mache so
ich liebe Zitrone aber die schmeckt ja
die schmeckt richtig gut so die ist so
richtig schön herzhaft salzig lecker
welches Gericht welche Speise kochst du
am liebsten
selber machen
mit deiner selbst gemacht
die wir hier auch vor uns stehen haben
auch komplett selbst gemacht
deshalb freue ich mich auch darauf das
Brot wie heißt dieses Brot hier vorne
ich dachte vielleicht Börek aber Börek
ist mit ist mit wie sagt man Blätterteig
und das hier ist Hefeteig eine Hefe
eine
[Musik]
alles zusammen
warten okay
super ist man das zu der Suppe oder wie
isst man das alles sehr egal
newslettering gehen oder
kann man auch essen man kann das immer
essen einfach okay ja
das ist innen drin gefüllt mit
Schafskäse und Spinat oder welche sind
die Kräuter Petersilie Petersilie ja und
das fühlt sich so gut an dafür liebe ich
so türkische Backwaren sind sowas
herzhafte backward angeht eigentlich die
Beste auf der Welt finde ich bist du in
der Türkei oder in Deutschland geboren
zwei Kinder geboren
Türkei und dann meine Mann da
Deutschland gekommen und dann hast du in
der Türkei das Kochen gelernt ja ja
immer Türkei okay schön zum Glück zum
Glück bist du hier dass ich bei dir
essen kann
ich probiere jetzt Botschaft türkische
Botschaft noch nie gegessen und es fühlt
sich allein schon so weich an
bin so neidisch auf dich Alter vor allem
mit Milch das heißt das ist ja dann so
ein türkisches Milchbrötchen aber
trotzdem mit Schafskäse der Sesam oben
drauf steht der gibt auch immer so viel
Geschmack schmeckt auch immer so richtig
richtig türkisch wenn Sesam oben drauf
dann weiß man ist türkisch aber das ist
sehr lecker was also alles schmeckt
super mehr schmeckt sehr sehr sehr
lecker das Brot auch sehr sehr lecker
heute bin ich ja dein Gast heute kochst
du für mich normalerweise ihr habt ja
auch einen tiktok Kanal kostet für deine
Enkelin oder wie ist das für dich ist
das komisch ist das neu wie ist das für
dich im Internet Videos zu machen
[Gelächter]
die Leute schreiben die nette Kommentare
die schreiben Oma kann super kaufen
aber ich finde es schön also das Gute
ist auch wenn wir nicht perfekt sprechen
können weil Sprache ich verstehe dann
Essen das Essen schmeckt so da weiß ich
ich verstehe deine Sprache vom Essen das
ist wirklich köstlich also er hat
schmeckt das Brot super auch besser als
in jedem Restaurant man merkt auf jeden
Fall das nicht das erste Mal dass sie
diese Suppe gemacht hat weil das stimmt
alles also so wie die gesalzen ist diese
gebraute Butter mit den Kräutern die
Zitrone darin schmeckt auch super gut
also dafür muss
einfach mal probieren weil das ist so
lecker finde ich dieses buttrige dieses
wolkige das ist so weich hat zu diesem
sesamt
ich habe Glück dass ich das nicht jeden
Tag bekomme weil sonst würde ich noch
dicker
[Musik]
das sieht wieder aus wie gemein es sieht
sehr sehr schön aus was ist dieses
Gericht klar Reis Reisnudeln und das da
drüben das ist eine Aubergine
ein bisschen Wasser aufgeschüttet habe
ich gesehen Du hast auch verschiedene
Soßen wir haben hier eine Joghurtsoße
mit Aubergine
[Musik]
Aubergine ist butterzart die zerfällt
richtig im Mund du kannst versuchen sie
zu kauen aber du kannst sie nicht mehr
kaufen ist wirklich wie Butter hier
haben wir die Füllung noch mit auf der
Gabel also Rinderhackfleisch Paprika
bisschen was Grünes eine Kartoffel auch
noch dabei mit dieser selbstgemachten
Tomatensoße
ich frage mich wenn du über sagst du
bist mit 26 bist du aus der Türkei nach
Deutschland gekommen ist dann so dass
die türkische Küche zu kochen für dich
auch so ein bisschen Sonne so hammer ist
ein Heimatgefühl
[Gelächter]
du hast die Türkei mitgebracht
Türkei ist ja bestimmt auch Heimat für
dich und so kannst du auch hier in
Deutschland türkisches Essen türkisches
Gefühl
ja besser
wie lecker ist dann dein Essen in der
Türkei dann ist zu gut zum Glück zum
Glück essen wir hier sonst wäre es zu
lecker ich sag nicht aus Höflichkeit das
alles so lecker ist weil es ist wirklich
so lecker also jede einzelne Sache die
probiert habe schmeckt wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr gut und genau das ist ja
so dieses bei Oma Essen so deshalb haben
wir jetzt auch dieses Format ins Leben
gerufen weil so können wir quasi die
Landesküche von verschiedenen Ländern
erleben in der reinsten und besten
Formen nämlich von der Oma die gerne
kocht und Goethe gekocht gerne oder
kann nur gut schmecken
man merkt sie hat ja auch gesagt dass
sie viel Wert auf gute Zutaten legt
vieles selbst macht wie auch den Joghurt
und so und so diese Frische und Qualität
von den einzelnen Bestandteilen schmeckt
man wirklich also wirklich bei jeder
Gabe egal was man probiert etwas so gut
schmecken zu lassen dann fragt man sich
natürlich auch wer hat dir denn das
Kochen beigebracht
also es wurde auch Dir quasi
weitergegeben
wirklich gerade wenn man so gut kochen
kann muss man es weitergehen sonst darf
nicht verloren gehen hast du auch so ein
Rezeptbuch oder ist alles im Kopf alles
im Kopf nicht geschrieben
dennoch oder nicht genug ja immer auch
schmecken selbst probieren testen müsst
wirklich auch mal vorbeischauen tik tok
Youtube sonst wie Ihr auf dem Kanälen
von Gülcan und ihrer Enkelin die beiden
kochen zusammen das zuckersüß und man
kann vor allem auch lernen wie man diese
leckeren Gerichte kochen kann Oma kocht
am besten ich verlinke euch auch alles
schaut da unbedingt mal vorbei ich kann
Euch so viel sagen Oma kocht wirklich am
besten also ist alles so lecker so
liebevoll und dass wir hier als gestern
empfangen wurden ist auf jeden Fall echt
schön freue mich auch auf alles was das
Format noch bringt so die verschiedenen
Küchen noch mal so durch diese
Perspektive quasi zu erleben weil ich
habe ja einfach mal indem ich selbst
koche aber das von aus der Hand von oben
quasi gezeigt zu bekommen ist glaube ich
das beste was man machen kann als
Abschluss zu jedem türkischen Essen
gehört natürlich ein scheiß und hier
sind Plätzchen könnt ihr euch live auf
tiktok anschauen wie die gebacken wurden
das ist das aktuellste tiktok in sehr
gespannt wie sie sind 330.000 Leute
haben euer tiktok schon gesehen
kannst nicht anders sagen
also wirklich ich auch sehr sehr lecker
du kannst wirklich gut kochen
denn so zu fluffig zu bröselkekse also
richtig lecker ihr seid wirklich
gastfreundlich es war ein schöner Tag
glaube das ist auch ein gutes endwort
für unser Video türkische Küche von der
türkischen Oma viel besser wird's nicht
ich freue mich auf die nächsten Folgen
danke fürs zuschauen danke dass du dabei
warst wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder macht's gut bis dahin tschüss
ach so und schreibt unbedingt in die
Kommentare ob ich das Video gefallen hat
ob ich das Format gefällt und wenn ihr
eine Oma habt wo ihr sagt die kocht so
gut und die möchte auch meine Video
dabei sein dann schreibt mir auf
Instagram schick mir vielleicht
irgendwie am besten noch ein kleines
Video mit oder so möchte bei allen Omas
Essen heute erst recht